Jeremy renner's thinking fans for all
the love after suffering from a serious
injury I really couldn't be more
fortunate could not feel more fortunate
the actor assured his followers he'll be
okay with this selfie from his hospital
bed writing quote thank you all for your
kind words I'm too messed up now to type
but I send love to you all after
enduring injuries from a snow plow
accident over the weekend Jeremy was
hospitalized and underwent immediate
surgery his rep shared an update with
E.T revealing he's making positive
progress and is awake talking and in
good spirits as of Tuesday the actor
remains in the ICU in critical but
stable condition his family asked for
continued thoughts from fans while he
heals with his loved ones nearby myself
and all the members of the Washoe County
Sheriff's Office family and First
Responders send our thoughts and prayers
to Mr Renner his family and friends and
we share our sincere hope for a full and
speedy recovery the Sheriff's Office
revealed details of the incident during
a press conference on Tuesday based on
our investigation Mr reynard's personal
vehicle which was being driven by a
family member had become snuck in the
snow near his home
Mr Renner went to retrieve his piston
bully or snow cat an extremely large
piece of snow removal equipment weighing
at least 14
330 pounds in an effort to get his
vehicle moving after successfully Towing
his personal vehicle from its stuck
location Mr Rainer got out of his piston
bully at this point is observed that the
Piston bullish started to roll
in an effort to stop the rolling piston
bully Mr Renner attempts to get back
into the driver's seat it's at this
point that Mr Renner is run over by the
Piston bullet Jeremy was then airlifted
to a local hospital after suffering
blunt chest trauma and Orthopedic
injuries
the Marvel star who lives outside of
Reno has posted videos and photos with a
plow in the past
[Music]
alongside this 2021 video Jeremy shared
his love for the mountain weather
writing quote I have so much respect for
Mother Earth and mother nature I expect
to lose the fight but I'll always give
it my best shot and in another quote
Monday morning pre-winter preparation
couldn't be more fun hashtag Reno
hashtag Tahoe
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]